وخرجت من الماء أولاً
وظهرت على لوحي وقلت
حسنًا يا بقرة مقدسة، لقد فقدت ساقي،
ديف سمين، يمكنني الضحك على ذلك الآن،
كان الجميع يقولون يا إلهي، يا إلهي،
أين فقدت ذلك؟  هذه
صور من رحلته بقوارب الكاياك في بحيرة
ناتوما قبل عام عندما خرج من
الماء وبطريقة ما انزلقت ساقه الاصطناعية
في ساقه وظل في
قاع البحيرة لمدة عام تقريبًا الآن
مفقودًا لمدة عام حتى الأسبوع الماضي هذا
يُظهر مقطع فيديو تحت الماء لحظة
اكتشاف الساق الاصطناعية
[موسيقى]
لقد حدث ذلك للتو، وقد
سبح الغواص مات سبروتنبرغ
داخلها، كم كان من المميز العثور على هذه
الساق الاصطناعية ثم العثور على
الشخص الذي تنتمي
إليه، لقد كان
متطوعو سبروتنبرغ المذهلون من أجل  مجموعة
تدعى "النهر الأمريكي المفقود" ووجدوا
أنهم ينشرون اكتشافاتهم على
صفحة فيسبوك، رصدت إحدى الأصدقاء الأكثر سمنة
المنشور وتعرفت على ساقها
على الفور، وقالت: يا إلهي،
لن تخمن أبدًا
ما نشره شخص ما على فيسبوك وما الذي
يحمله  رفعت صورة
للساق وقلت حسنًا، هذه ساقي
فقالت إنني أعرف أنه فقد
ساقه خلال يوم في البحيرة ثم وجد
إيمانه بالإنسانية. المغزى من
القصة هو أنهم ما زالوا أشخاصًا طيبين في
هذا  الدولة العالمية أنهم ما زالوا أناس طيبين